يتحقق
السلام اذا اعترف المجتمع الدولي ان اصل
المشكله هو الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يتحقق
السلام اذا اعترف المجتمع الدولي ان اصل
المشكله هو الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واذا اتخذ
خطوات عمليه وجديه لانهاء هذا الاحتلال
دون ذلك لن يتحقق السلام لان الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي لم يبدا يوم 7 تشرين
نحن نشهد هذا الصراع منذ قيام دوله
اسرائيل عام
1948 وبالتاكيد منذ احتلالها للضفه
الغربيه
اي والقدس
وغزه عام 67
انا استطيع ان اقترح خطوات
عمليه لاطلاق عمليه سياسيه جاده تؤدي الى
انهاء الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ليس لانني مقتنع بان الظروف
مهيئه لمثل هذه
العمليه ولكن حتى نتعلم من اخطاء
الماضي وحتى لا ندخل في عمليه سياسيه
مفتوحه المدى لا تنتهي كما فعلنا في اسلو
وبالتالي ادت ذلك الى استمرار الصراع وانا
اعتقد ان اي عمليه سياسيه جاده يجب ان
تبدا من نقطتين اولا تحديد الهدف النهائي
للمفاوضات وهو انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلال فتره زمنيه محدده لنقل ثلاث الى خمس
سنوات وثانيا اعتراف المجتمع الدولي من
خلال قرار يصدر من الامم المتحده بدوله
فلسطين على اساس حدود 67 قبل بدء
المفاوضات ان قبل المجتمع الدولي بذلك
تصبح المفاوضات حول الخطوات التي يجب
اتخاذها من اجل الوصول الى هذا الهدف وليس
كما كان في السابق مفاوضات حول الهدف
النهائي وما اذا كان هو انهاء الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ام
لا اصلله كانت عمليه سياسيه مدتها خمس
سنوات ولكن انها لم تحدد الهدف النهائي
وبالتالي
مر 30 عاما على اوسلو دون ان يتحقق هدف
انهاء الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مره اخرى ان تم الاتفاق على
هذا الهدف النهائي وعلى الاعتراف بدوله
فلسطين يمكن لنا
ان نعود الى الوراء ونبدا بالخطوات الواجب
اتخاذها
مثلا من سيحكم غزه بعد هذه الحرب الشعوه
من سيحكم غزه
يصبح الاتفاق حول
ذلك واحده من الخطوات التي يجب اتخاذها
وليس هدفا نهائيا بحد ذاته مثلا من سيعيد
اعمار غزه ايضا يصبح هذا واحده من الخطوات
الواجب اتخاذها دون ان تصبح الهدف النهائي
لان احدا اليوم لن يقوم باباده اعمار غزه
اذا استمر العدوان
الاسرائيلي واذا تم تدمير ما يتم اعاده
اعماره في المستقبل كما فعلت اسرائيل ذلك
العديد من المرات اذا لم يقبل المجتمع
الدولي بذلك وانا اعتقد ان الظروف غير
مهيئه لان الولايات المتحده مشغوله
بانتخاباتها
الرئاسيه
واسرائيل حتى لو اتت حكومه جديده ليس من
الواضح انها ستكون حكومه اكثر مرونه
بالنسبه للعمليه السياسيه باعتبار ان
الانقسام في اسرائيل اليوم ليس انقساما
بين معسكر السلام ومعسكر الحرب هو انقسام
بين من مع نتنياهو ومن
ضده وهناك حاجه لانتخابات ايضا فلسطينيه
لتحديد الجهه التي او الجهات التي ستمثل
الجانب الفلسطيني
باعتبار ان اليوم السلطه الوطنيه الفلسط
لا تتمتع ب قبول واسع ومن الضروري
بمكان ان تقوم هناك انتخابات فلسطينيه
لتحديد من سيمثل الجانب
الفلسطيني ان لم نستطع الاتفاق على كل هذه
الخطوات فانا اخشى ان
البديل سيكون استمرار العنف
واستمرار المقاومه
المسلحه ليس فقط في غزه وانما ايضا في
الضفه الغربيه و
شهدنا امثله واضحه على ذلك من عرين الاسود
وغيرها من الكتائب التي شكلت قبل حتى سب
تشرين انا اخشى اننا سندخل في مثل هذه
العمليه لفتره طويله من
الزمن
حتى يدرك المجتمع الدولي ان غياب حل
الدولتين
معناه الوحيد برايي هو الاع را بالحقوق
المتساويه
للفلسطينيين مع الجانب الاسرائيلي وان اي
حل مهما كان شكله في المستقبل ان لم يكن
مبنيا على الحقوق المتساويه للجانبين فلن
يكتب له النجاح او
الاستدامه
وخشيتي ان هذا الصراع سيستمر الى
وقت لان جديه المجتمع الدولي في تنفيذ
الخطوات التي
طرحتها جديه مشكوك فيها الى ابعد
الحدود
ا